Sekti Aidenia không tâm thiện vực, đón sống hạ tần biểu. Kế thưa trọn vệnh hệ ra chỉ của
FT Sekti Bởi Hét, tập loàn bất đổ sản hàng đầu đông năm á. Bởi hơn 5.9 viểu
tưởng dí sản tòn cầu như巴特斯, Phàu Stinson, nơi áp buồn lợi trọn làm chủ sở tại
anh. Sekti Aidenia là biểu tượng cho trận sống Quốc tế, cùng với tiêm năng ra chỉ tăng trưởng theo
thời gian. Sekti Aidenia toạ laxin mặt tiền Quốc lộ huy ba và nắm sữ vị chi chúng
tâm của vùng kinh tế phiế đông bắt thành phố chiming. Từ Sekti Aidenia mất mối phút xin chuyển tiếp cận hệ tự ít hiện
đại của khu vực đáp ứng mọi như câu sống, học tập, làm việc dài chi như, loa tế
mắt, e-on-mon, bình viện Quốc tế biệt ca mê. Đặc biệt, Sekti Aidenia còn được bó bộ
bởi mình săng di sản 25.9i một ốc đạo sang hiểm có dưới đô thị năng đầu. Sekti Aidenia
còn đón trọn lần sống hạ tần như, được phành đài bà, cuối lộ 18 mở dộ sống miếc
và miếc cho 8 bây bối ra cầu ông Bộ cách dự án mối phút di bộ. Sekti Aidenia không chỉ mang đến
cơ hội ăn cư li tưởng mà còn là khoản đô tư tìm năng trong tự lạy.